[Music]
so
my experience that i want to share
right now because i feel like it's going
to help me a lot
to heal it's like when i was 16
i got pregnant from my first boyfriend
we were in a serious relationship
and i didn't know anything about life by
the time
and i ended up not having the kid like i
had an abortion
and coming where i come from which is
from south america
it's a very bad situation like i did the
abortion myself at home like i put some
pills inside my body
and i started to have contractions it
was pretty bad
and i didn't have access to like health
care either because
of course they were going to like call
my parents and stuff and i didn't want
to do it so
i just remained you know in my room the
whole time like suffering having
contractions
like i almost died like i almost had a
sepsis
almost got infected and i feel like
that taught me so many things by the
time and right now i feel like
if i would go through the same situation
i would definitely keep the baby um
of course i feel bad for the baby but
honestly i feel bad for a woman because
we are
being judged no matter what like no
matter what the decision is
we are being judged and i would
definitely
keep the baby and the lesson i want to
keep from this story is like basically
it's your body
and you should do whatever you feel more
comfortable with
i did it because my parents were very
strict with me
and i felt like i i wouldn't be able to
go through
the whole process of telling them i was
pregnant without being kicked out of my
house
honestly yeah that's definitely that's
gonna remain
in my mind forever and i just wanted to
talk it all out today because i think
that's gonna help me heal a lot
thank you
so i'm a really open person i don't
really have very many secrets
but i guess a secret for myself
is i'm afraid of
not loving myself one day i'm afraid
that i'll never
learn that i'm not necessarily insecure
about how i look or
what i'm capable of it's more of just
my heart is insecure so
i want to be able to find that one day
and i hope
one day i'm able to fully love myself
for who i am
and to be okay with being alone
[Music]
all right my secret is
that i have had a crush
on one of my very close friends for a
very long time
and uh i don't know what to do with that
information
yeah all right so you were the person
who just went you said you have a crush
on your friend
i do and you're willing to call them
right now i
am willing to call her right now i'm
just gonna be like i've been into you
since like the first time i saw you
because you're incredibly talented and
beautiful
oh yeah she's also sitting right there
uh
she came to visit me from pennsylvania
so yeah i'm so nervous
is it okay if i curse that's fine okay
damn
this is so chaotic
how are you hey
nan that's it
um jinx
oh bet okay
cute
anyways this is the person i called
did you have any idea should we call you
no i didn't
are you serious i really didn't know i
was asking i was like is it gonna be
somebody from home
and it was like i don't think so and i
was like
how do you feel how do you feel um
kind of surprised what because
i well uh you're like a a show-stopping
individual i never thought that you
would have a crush on me and i like
had a crush on you for a really long
time but i never said it
so
fast yeah
i'm a pretty forward person yeah this is
the least forward i've ever seen you
because like
if it has been festering for a while i'm
surprised that it took you this long man
you're so intimidating
seriously yeah you're also very
intimidated
thank you those are the final thoughts
yeah
good job thank you
[Music]
every time i meet a guy that i like i
always like
search up his address and like look at
his house
and like see if it's nice or not like
see how much it's worth so
[Music]
this is my secret so my
great uncle's daughter's ex-husband
killed my great uncle and the ex-husband
has been on the run
ever since and it's been like three
years
[Music]
my secret is that i was a vegetarian
only for the cloud
[Music]
i plan on moving away and telling nobody
every time someone's ever tried to stop
me i've listened
i've decided i'm not going to listen
anymore
my secret is i fantasize a lot about my
wedding day and my funeral
because they're the only two events for
the rest of my life where all of my
family and friends and loved ones will
be in the same place at the same time i
fantasize a lot about the
the music and the playlist at these
events because music is a big part of my
life and
it makes me laugh to think that i would
uh let my my mom be in charge of my
funeral music
because i just know that she's gonna
butcher that um
but the irony is i fantasize a lot about
my wedding day and my funeral but
i will only be at one of them
[Music]
hi uh i
spent a month in a mental ward a string
of events
from i want loco
but for many reasons uh we can do a pbs
documentary about it
[Laughter]
i had a friend that passed um
[Music]
and
i couldn't focus on school and failed
out
of ucla my last quarter and so the only
answer my parents thought was like the
mental ward
me kanye west meadow world peace
all kicked in the same mental ward
what's up
[Music]
i have a bacterial growth in my armpits
that caused them
caused my hairs to turn neon orange
[Music]
so my secret is that when i was younger
i was at gymnastics camp and we had a
water day where we played with water
balloons and stuff
and so after the day almost everyone was
in the bathroom like changing out of
their
clothes and stuff and i was in the gym
with my friend
and i was like oh i need to go to the
bathroom so i asked
our coach if i could go to the bathroom
and she said no because there were too
many people
in the bathroom so i was like okay
that's
okay and so then i started walking along
the floor
and i started peeing and then i jumped
into the
foam pit because i had to pee and i
wanted to hide it and so i just jumped
in the phone
kept peeing and then somebody ran by and
stepped in it
and then i told my friend i said you
need to go tell the coach
that the floor is wet so my friend went
up to the coach and was like
the floor is wet with water and i said
no that's my
pee and so and the coach was like go to
the bathroom right now and i was like
fine you didn't even let me go to the
bathroom so of course i had to pee on
your floor
like i don't know and then later i was
talking my friend and she was like
why did you do that and i was like
are you kidding me i had to pee and
yeah that's my secret
when i was 18 i went to
a um sex club
in new york city and had
sex with a number of men and it turns
out that almost all of the men there
were
married and i only found out um
because i saw the man's phone screen
and it was his wife and kids
[Music]
when i was in middle school i used to go
to the local high school's football
games and beat up kids my age
i have no idea why i did it but
eventually the police started looking
for me and they never found me
and looking back on this i'm incredibly
disappointed in myself
and i can't imagine why i would ever do
something like that in the first place
it's just horrible
trying to be happy today it's kind of
hard
just because the family problems i have
and i just wish that everyone going
through hard times
can stay strong if you have family
problems you're never alone i've had
three failed pregnancies
[Music]
12 years ago to the day
when i turned 17 i
can attempted to commit suicide
but failed 12 years later
[Music]
i wonder if i will ever start to feel
that way again
and i'm just concerned
that one day i could get back to that
dark place
and i just don't know what to do about
it
oh you thought i was going to share a
secret maybe next time
um hi everyone i just wanted to hop on
here real quick and give a shout out and
thank the 93 people who signed up for my
membership
you'll see their names on the screen i
recently decided to put the join button
on my channel to help fund my projects
in new cities around the world
and to help fund a second camera woman
who's gonna capture the behind the
scenes for you guys
so thank you for signing up you're truly
helping make that dream come true
and thanks to all of you regardless of
if you did or didn't sign up because
you've made so many of my dreams come
true
already i love you guys and i'll see you
next time